irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport jacques perron rédacteur en
chef du journal télévisé vient d'aller
au japon en compagnie de claude fayard
et il nous a rapporté le son voyage
s'est vu
j'étais roux nous continuons notre
voyage au japon mais cette fois les vues
prises d'être oui et vous allez
remarquer qu'une fuite une chose c'est
que dans les wagons de ce train il n'y a
pas deux compartiments ils sont pour
l'instant avec le wattman ces actes
indécents du mi6 tournée que devait y
arrivera vous remarquez pas de
compartiments mais une possibilité en
actionnant un levier de mettre les
sièges parce à face sur la conversation
par exemple un autre détail aussi chacun
de ces trains est pourvu d'un bar d'un
bar qui à toute heure du jour est admis
peut vous servir soit des boissons
fraîches ou chaudes soit des le
véritable petit repas tel que consommer
dans le train voilà précisément ce bar
et à chaque minute des serveuses passé
prennent les commandes et vous apporte
immédiatement les rafraîchissements où
la nourriture devait commander d'un
aspect particulier de ce train qui par
ailleurs sont extrêmement propre et sont
dotés aussi autres détails que j'avais
oublié son doté de haut parleurs ce qui
permet au chef de train qui est en tête
d'annoncé attention nous allons arriver
à cette gare ce qui est
là vous y passez pas manquer cette dame
à elle mangeait tous y avait dans son
carton exactement voici le contrôleur
qui portent des gants blancs j'ai
remarqué
je crois qu'on a toujours le droit
d'exiger la conduit à exalead en or
blanc alors ici nous sommes à nico et ce
pont ce pont rouge et n'est utilisé que
par l'empereur quand il vient en
pèlerinage à nico nico est un parc
national au centre duquel se trouve le
sanctuaire de tout shaggy ou nous
pouvons actuellement le tout chaque bus
ou a lieu à péter lainage annuelle de
chaque but qui est un amoncellement de
pagodes et de temples je trouve même
qu'il y en a trop c'est très richement
décoré est vraiment cessé site est alors
voilà les trois singes de la sagesse ne
rien dire ne rien voir ne rien entendre
ces singes qui sont produits à des
centaines ou milliers d'exemplaires soit
en boutons de manchette en foulard
enfants d'ul ou en broche alors ce
temple bien entendu on le visite il faut
absolument se déchausser pour ne pas
abîmer les tatamis qui sont les tapis de
paille de riz sur les ténors circulent
en chaussettes jusque et y compris quand
on est président du conseil de la
république comme tu m'énerves ils
ont marqué que des gens ne peuvent pas
beaucoup sur cet inconnu pour ses pulls
et oui c'est un établissement secondaire
l oms et ses collégiens porte un
uniforme assez sévères alors là nous
sommes passés diamétralement au sud tout
ça est un coupé dès que j'ai vu face et
le voyage qu'a voulu ça nous sommes au
grand bouddha de kamakura c'est un des
grand bouddha de du japon il fait 13
mètres de haut et il est en bronze c'est
le dégoût dessous c'est le nom japonais
du gouda
kamakura dans une petite ville au bord
de la mer voici les offrandes au bouddha
chaque jour des fruits dans une coupe
ici maintenant
à la période de la floraison des
cerisiers ce n'est pas très avancé vous
remarquez une fenêtre dans l'eau du
bouddha je crois que le gardien y
habitent et vit d'ailleurs cessé les
creux il date de 700 ans
voici quelques faits vue de la petite
ville de kamakura
est ici un visiteur qui nous a semblé en
train de se libérer de quelques
complexes chaouk c'est le seul pouce que
j'ai jamais vu tirer pendant notre
séjour au japon
n'ont pratiquement s'est ainsi presque
devenu un véhicule de musées ou ski très
trop épuisant ah oui tout à fait alors
nous allons passer maintenant dans une
région proche au bâtiment qui abrite un
autre grand bouddha lors c'est le plus
grand bouddha du japon le bouddha de
nara ici des gens qui déposent des
sources de contenus cierges qui brûlent
en dégageant un parfum dans tranquille
plantes dans le sable ces petits chiens
je les achète à l'entrée et les
accompagnants sommes leurs voeux les
voeux qu'ils font au bouddha voilà le
bâtiment qui à 57 mètres de haut le
gouda lui-même ayant 17 mètres de haut
voici d'ailleurs la reproduction
extérieur de ce bouddha qu'on ne peut
pas par l'intérieur puisque c'est très
très sombre ici un personnage qui a
l'air d'un prêtre qui est en réalité un
soldat qui mutile et qui fait la quête
pour son propre compte ici là le
pavillon d'or ce qu'on appelle pavillon
d'or c'est près de tokyo il s'appelle en
réalité le temps de recompte j il date
du 14ème siècle et il a été restauré
très récemment entre 50 et 55 et il
vraiment un aspect extraordinaire tout
en or tout doré c'est vraiment très
curieux d'un côté un vieux pluie où l'on
puisse toujours delaune enfin si
l'aspect traditionnel et surtout je dois
l'avouer pour les touristes ici le parc
qui entoure ce pavillon d'or avec
vraiment d'un paysage toutes ses cartes
postales mais je ça correspond tout à
fait à la réalité
ça vous posant oui tout à fait
voilà un lac petit lac sur fondeur le
cerisier et enfin le fuji yama fuji yama
qui est la montagne la plus haute du
japon le feuillet masse est en effet
3700 mètres de haut et le fuji yama joue
dans cette région on joue c'est à dire
de l'île centrale du japon est aussi
omniprésente que par exemple cervin à
cervinia ou à zermatt c'est vraiment le
monde qu'on voit de partout il s'impose
on lève les yeux on voit le fuit et il
est surtout très isolé il n'y a pas de
pré fuji comme il ya des préalpes par
exemple et
on le voit de partout ici le lac est un
l'ex black achi qui est situé dans le
parc national du fuji a connaît le foot
y'a connaît c'est une région extrêmement
pittoresque de lanzhou
les centrales du japon que je voulais
dire
très beaux paysages il ya des sites
magnifiques et des stations thermales
l'altitude is it à peu près de 4 à 500 m
ici un vendeurs de colifichets comme il
y en a partout partout il ya des
puristes vous voyez le fuji est vraiment
le cône le plus régulier de jeunesse
il s'agit de
1-2 teinturier oui c'est le rinçage le
rinçage des toiles imprimées il paraît
que l'autre c'est rivière a des qualités
particulières de fixation des couleurs
c'est lui moi ce que je me suis laissé
dire
est ici alors il s'agit du colza alcoa
qui est la matière première qui fournit
l'huile aux japonais qui donne
d'ailleurs quand on le voit d'avion
quand on voit simplement d'une certaine
altitude on voit des petits carrés
jaunes c'est très caractéristique du
pack du paysage japonais
wikipédia je connais dit par ailleurs
très vert mais avec ces tâches ces
carrés jaunes
les surpopulation oui c'est ça il s'agit
de deux femmes ces illustres en somme
l'emploi de la main d'oeuvre qui ne
coûtent pas cher au japon le standard de
vie relativement peu élevé l'ouvrier
spécialisé par exemple quand même
quelque chose que 20000 yens par mois ce
qui représente à peu près 25 mille
francs
toutes ces statues sont nés des
reliquats du passé bien entendu
ici une maison japonaise et qui illustre
un peu la vie tel que le pratique les
les japonais dans certain standing déjà
oui cette femme qui va retrouver son
enfant qui est avide taf à la japonaise
avec le kimono d'aller voir tout à
l'heure ses chaussures
c'étaient les pousse d'ailleurs d'un de
nos guides
japonais qui nous avaient très
courtoisement mais chez lui
renvoyer l ceux des choses ici elle
porte des sandales à semelles compensées
en somme ils vont marquer ses
chaussettes particulière avec un doigt à
ce qui lui permet de glisser vos orteils
et d'autres voies entre 7 lanières
nous entrons dans la maison d'ailleurs
pour l'heure du thé
nous qui est servi par une servante qui
est également kimono alors le premièr
premiers soins on offre aux à l'hôte des
serviettes des petites serviettes
avec de l'eau tiède spa des serviettes
hume était à l'eau tiède ceci pour se
laver les mains quand vous entrez dans
un bar d'ailleurs on vous offre ces
serviettes bien avant de vous demander
ce que vous prenez
là vous prenez le tennis ce genre de
gobelets
qui lui aussi très japonais
est une décoration murale une
reproduction d'un daoud un dieu
quelconque de culte au japon
alors voyez la différence avec laquelle
2 s'incline la servante
c'est également très caractéristique des
de la civilisation japonaise
ce n'est pas une geisha ça c'est d'une
servante simplement kit service de ces
deux personnes
c'est mon bouquet oui c'est un art
japonaise ou comment
vraiment tard pour confectionner des
bouquets
photo gr 10 ionel photo traditionnel oui
c'est voilà c'est une illustration ce
que je vous ai tout à l'heure l'uniforme
extrêmement sévère des collégiens
japonais tout est noir les petits
chapeaux des sports des bas noirs
également c'est assez triste et c'est
assez c'est très sévère l'uniforme était
très militaire à peine à peine la tâche
claire des des imperméables qui sont
aussi uniforme d'ailleurs
passé la photo souvenir classique le bon
dans tout pays qui se respecte alors là
nous sommes tombés dans un petit village
dans une petite ville on peut dire sur
un cortège d'enfants dirige pas de
plusieurs centaines d'enfants là qui
tirait un char des enfants de 2 4 à 13
ans à peu près qui tirait un ch retrait
13 enluminés très enrubanné avec que
décoration extrêmement vive et il
s'agissait d'un épisode de la fête
anniversaire de bouddha ce char tiré par
ses enfants de les voir le fils thème de
freinage extrêmement rudimentaire
ce char tiré par des enfants donc
circuler très lentement à travers les
rues de la ville et il comportait deux
étages au premier étage on les verra à
peine d'ailleurs un groupe de musiciens
qui jouaient de ces instruments si
caractéristique du japon instruments à
cordes n'est ce pas histoire de faire du
bruit et d'attirer la population s'y
aventurent cette décoration chalands qui
n'avait pas tiré et au rez de chaussée
si je puis dire de ce chat il y avait
deux personnes à l'intérieur d'eux
quêteurs en somme de caissier si vous
voulez car il s'agissait en fait d'une
quête d'une quête pour le temple pour
les moines du temple local
est organisée dans la rue avec
grand renfort de population infantile
j'avoue que c'était extrêmement
extrêmement curieux
et nous voilà revenus à l'aéroport de
tokyo haneda notre petit voyage au japon
est terminée il a duré dix jours
exactement
nous allons rejoindre paris en moins de
30 heures via anchorage en alaska c'est
à dire une nuit et une journée ce qui
par rapport au voyage du sud représente
fut utilisée au début de cette émission
un gain de temps de 15 heures exactement
eh bien merci jacques perron de nous
avoir conduit aux jeux pan
ouais
c
à
oh
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de jacques
perron claude fayard insolence péters
montage jean-pierre les sons luke perry
ni illustration sonore denise glaser